[Music]
hey what's up
mkbhd here pixel 5
google pixel 5. you know if you think
about it it's actually kind of funny
that
google makes smartphones just because
you know you and me both know
google as a software company and an ads
company but
we really know their specialty is
software yet every year we have these
huge expectations like they're going to
blow our minds with some amazing pixel
hardware
but they never do they never really do
because pixel hardware has never
actually been
that great they've never had the best
screens
or the best designs they've never had
the biggest sensors or the most ram
pixel has never really been about that
so now it just seems that 2020
is the year google not just recognizes
that but
embraces that the pixel is all about the
software so they're not even making a
thousand dollar
crazy high-end flagship hardware phone
this year that i'm gonna try the pixel 5
is 6.99 and it's just a vessel for all
the best
software that google makes and the
result
is a pretty nice phone it's a pretty
nice phone not some mind blowing
bleeding edge hard ass phone just
a nice phone this metal build losing
those hardware bells and whistles from
last year i actually think made it
better to be honest
so no radar system up in the top in the
huge bezel for some flashy gestures i'll
never use and face unlock
instead just a selfie camera cut out all
screen up on the front of this phone
thin symmetrical bezels like i said it's
not a stretch to say this is the best
looking
front of a pixel ever just by keeping it
simple
the back material we kept getting told
by google that it's metal
right and it is but then that metal is
underneath a coating of this kind of
soft touch textured plastic it seems
like it's wearing well
it doesn't have any staining problems or
anything like that except the power
button
is still glossy that's a little
different from the rest of the body
but yeah the result is this pretty clean
and well-built design
no seams i've seen some headlines of
people getting pixels that weirdly have
the back
slightly detached like separated from
the front glass piece here
super odd but clearly mine doesn't have
that issue at all it's water resistant
which is awesome
there's a classic fast reliable
fingerprint reader back here that can
double
as a notification shade pull down if
you're into that and then there's a cut
out
in the back for wireless charging which
is clever but overall
pretty understated i would say the phone
is small it's a six inch edge to edge
display
but it's small it's smaller than the
iphone 12 smaller than a lot of other
flagships
and i think a lot of people appreciate
that and i don't know what it is about
this green
tech all this green stuff coming out but
yeah green's not really my color i would
probably do the other color which is
black
or big brain status you can grab a case
from channel sponsor dbrand and pick any
color you want
and they've actually been refining their
materials on this grip case
which has this new texture along the
sides with literally tens of thousands
of these tiny little micro dots on the
surface to give you more grip
so it kind of feels like a tame version
of that old one plus sandstone
so if you want to get a grip link will
be below that like button as always so
okay they definitely took a step back
from the the premium hardware of
previous years
even on the inside the vibration motor
in this phone
has taken a step down it's a very
standard kind of sloppy feeling regular
vibration motor no headphone jack
no earpiece speaker too so the stereo
image from this
speaker pair is a little bit weaker all
of which would normally be
really disappointing in a sequel to a
flagship
but i guess you can't really look at
this phone as a sequel to a flagship
it's a
different price point it's 6.99 so it's
actually not really shocking at all the
display on the front
is par for the course it's a six inch
diagonal 1080p
90hz oled and with a pretty nice colors
and a decent max brightness
it's not you know quite the eye
searingly bright for outdoor visibility
that the flagships are but it's good
enough for everything else
and i'll go back to the overall
aesthetic these bezels are thin all the
way around
even through the corners and most people
including me
are just going to really like this
display but and it
hurts me to say this i can tell the
difference between this
90 hertz display and some of the 120
hertz displays in some other phones in
this price range
now again most people won't and it's
kind of fair to point that out but this
is my review and you would want to know
the things that i noticed so this is
something i'm noticing
and if you care about this type of stuff
you'd want to know that you can see the
difference
so now you know phones like the oneplus
8t and the galaxy s20
fan edition feel to me noticeably
smoother than this phone
now this phone is also trying to
throttle down from 90 hertz all the time
and you might have to force 90 hertz to
keep it at 90 hertz but generally
if you'd want to know that now you know
but most people won't have any problem
with this 90hz display also there aren't
very many snapdragon 765g
phones at 120 hertz so this setup really
is more balanced between
performance and efficiency and this
phone this phone never really felt
slow which is good it just never felt
quite as fast
as 120hz flagship to my calibrated eye
and i think that's actually more because
of the display than the chip so a lot of
people got mad because
pixel was going down to a snapdragon
765g
which is technically a weaker performer
on paper
than the one in the phone that came
before it how could they do that but i
actually think this was a great idea for
the efficiency gains
and this is actually a performance
difference that i think no one
including myself would actually notice
so when you combine this chip
and eight gigs of ram with google's
software wizardry
you get a phone that feels just fine in
everyday use and performance
and even through gaming and a battery
life that's
actually mind-blowing i failed to kill
this phone in a day
every single day for two weeks now i
realize
this is quarantine life and i'm not in a
5g area
so um this isn't the hardest possible
use that this phone will ever see but
the fact that i'm ending a lot of days
with four hours of screen on time
and 50 battery left
to me says this battery is pretty much
good to last all day for anyone even
forcing 90 hertz in the developer
settings like i mentioned earlier didn't
kill this phone much faster
keeping the screen on as often as
possible didn't kill this phone in a day
i'm telling you through gaming and
watching videos and navigation
and multitasking like this has been the
most pleasantly surprising battery
experience in a phone
in a while it just sips power but okay
you know how cameras have always been
the focus of the pixel line ever since
that pixel 2
leapfrogged everything well this camera
this camera is the maximum proof of
google's software over everything
approach this
camera uses the same sensor as that
pixel 2. so since then
sensors have clearly gotten way bigger
and higher resolution
and apertures have gotten wider and
hardware tech has advanced a lot
but google has stuck with their software
special of
maximizing not that amazing hardware
plus they went ahead and added an ultra
wide this year which is great
so yes i'm just going to say pixel 5
takes in my opinion still the best
looking photos
of any smartphone they still nail the
look because they haven't changed
it it's confident it's a contrasty look
with great detail
and dynamic range definitely my favorite
look
but the lead the pixel camera used to
have over the rest of the crowd
has narrowed a lot and honestly other
other smartphone cameras can do
things just as well sometimes better
with better hardware
better natural blur from bigger sensors
better detail from higher resolution
50 64 100 megapixel sensors
so it makes me wonder how much longer
google can keep sticking
to this formula i know mr mobile in his
video on the pixel 5 he compared
the note 20 ultra versus the pixel 5 at
night
and of course at night you get some
interesting observations about how a
bigger sensor gathers way more
light and can create real depth instead
of having to fake it with software
so really good video i'll link his
review below but yeah bottom line
pixel 5 camera is really really good
but i kind of wonder how much longer
this setup will have at the top
before the hardware work passes it
knowing google and their tendency to
lean on software
maybe they'll stick with it a little too
long the software is just still so
killer though i love the exposure and
contrast adjustment sliders that are
still here
also there's these little alignment
tricks for the horizon
and for it to take perfectly flat top
down shots
uh there's portrait lighting and
portrait light editing
inside of google photos which is crazy
i've never seen it before
but it it works really well and you've
got night sight
night sight selfies night sight portrait
mode
i like that it suggests portrait mode
now when it recognizes a person as a
subject
and the automatic night side switching
at nighttime when it detects a dark
scene
it's all basically software magic some
of it takes a little bit longer to
process though
since there's no dedicated image
processor anymore so it takes a few
seconds after snapping an image for the
765g to actually process it
free to view it and that doesn't feel as
premium when you have to wait for your
photo
but the weight is clearly worth it and
hey all the android 11 features all the
pixel features you could possibly want
are also here in this phone minus
squeeze for assistant but i think that's
because of the metal build they
got rid of that but google doesn't have
to hold back any software experiences to
protect
their higher end more expensive phones
from cutting sales from them
because this is their highest end most
expensive phone
so they get everything so the call
screen feature from last year is still
great the recorder app with live
transcription
and search still super useful the live
captioning of
any and all audio going through the
phone like videos are watching or music
lyrics or phone calls
and there's also some new stuff like the
new wallpaper picker preview
in android 11 and making google
assistant wait on hold for you
which i haven't gotten to work yet but
sounds like something google would
figure out how to do
so the pixel like the nexus that came
before it and even the google play
edition stuff
has has always been some of my favorite
android experiences
and there's just something about it but
this one's no different it's an
aesthetic
it's a feeling it's a look and the bonus
is you get to be right at the front of
the line for whatever stuff ends up in
the newest versions of android
down the road so at the end of the day
is the pixel 5
is this a good phone well here's my take
yeah pixel 5 is a good phone this is a
good device i think there's an argument
you could make that it should have been
like 5.99 instead of 6.99 and i honestly
wouldn't be surprised to see it on sale
for that on black friday and even after
that this year
but it's a good phone and also for those
who haven't been paying as much
attention the pixel 4a
5g is a very similar also good phone for
a lot of the same reasons
for 4.99 so i'm going to link that below
also but for those wondering about me
and am i going to make the pixel 5 my
new daily driver
this is the opposite of a normal caveat
you've heard me say before
it's not for everyone i you guys already
know i like
high quality cameras i like great
performance i like stock android
you would think that the pixel would be
for me but
i wish they had made a high-end
flagship version that goes the extra
mile with hardware
and some bells and whistles even knowing
it wouldn't sell that much i wish they
had made a version
with the neural core so that image
processing is a little faster
i wish they'd made a version with the
snapdragon 865 and
12 gigs of ram so performance is good
for longer i wish they'd made a version
with 120hz display so it feels
snappy all the time the battery can
clearly handle it
i wish they'd made a version that's a
little bigger it's just
a lot of little stuff that i'm so used
to on
flagships that this phone doesn't have
that i'm i feel like i'm missing now so
they decided to make a mid-range phone
which
let's be honest was a pretty smart idea
for them but uh for me
personally i'm going to be going back to
a higher end phone
i think just because that's what i'm
used to so for those wondering about me
that's me but if you're ever looking for
a master class on how to use
great software to turn a pretty good
smartphone into a really good smartphone
you're looking at it the pixel 5 that's
what pixel has been all about for so
long it's just them finally embracing it
and i'm glad to see it so well played
google
thanks for watching catch you guys the
next one
[Music]
peace